i think it's our natural state to be
connected
meghan markle makes a surprise
appearance in prince harry and oprah
winfrey's apple tv plus
docu-series the me you can't see
on monday the streaming service dropped
the first trailer for the pair's highly
anticipated project
what words have you heard around mental
health crazy
lost it with that stigma of being
labeled the other the telling of the
story
being able to say this is what happened
to me is crucial
megan makes two short cameos in the
trailer
first she stands behind her husband
wearing a statement t-shirt that says
raising the future the other is
previously seen footage of megan reading
to the couple's son
archie the results of this year will be
felt for decades
for kids families
husbands wives everybody the trailer
also features
some emotional moments from the talk
show icon and the duke of sussex
it's just something i accepted to make
that decision
to receive help is not a sign of
weakness
in today's world more than ever it is a
sign of strength
prince harry is committed to raising
awareness about mental health he has
made
this he and megan together have made
this one of their raisons tetra
um and as with the cambridges they are
going to do everything they can i think
to keep that spotlight on the importance
of
mental health and i think we should all
be expecting to be hearing
more of him about this conversation it's
something he's passionate about
he clearly believes in it he believes he
can make a difference
i think unfortunately for the royal
family it seems that prince harry is not
afraid
to draw on his own experiences in order
to relay the importance of mental health
and get his message out prince harry has
been open about his own mental health
journey
following the death of his mother
princess diana in august 1995.
it's a topic that seemingly will be
covered in the series
as viewers see footage of a young prince
harry walking behind her casket
treating people with dignity is the
first
act the trailer also features
appearances from stars such as lady gaga
who's billed by her birth name stephanie
i don't tell this story from my own
self-service
i've been through it and people need
help the series also features actress
glenn close
former toronto raptors player demar
derozan
robin williams son zach phoenix sons
player langston galloway
olympic boxer virginia ginny fuchs and
celebrity chef
rashad armstead all of them are visibly
emotional as they tell stories of their
own battles with mental health
i can put a smile on but inside feel
completely broken back in 2019
oprah opened up to cbs this morning
about how her latest partnership with
prince harry came to be
and why they decided to specifically
tackle mental health issues
i actually asked the question what do
you think are the most important
issues facing the world right now and he
said there are two
he said climate change and he said uh
mental wellness and i said oh you know
i'm going to be doing this thing with
apple i'm going i'm yeah
i said it's a big concern of mine too
and i was telling him about what this
apple platform and he said at the end of
the conversation oh if there's anything
i can do
to help and i got